all right norman
welcome back hey so how are things going
it's it's been uh since we met it's been
what a month and a half
a little over a month i think um what's
going on as of today
well uh as of today i have one day
uh we had a relapse that happened um
you know what i suffer from is
unpredictable you don't know when that
bucket's gonna hit you
you don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
this was one that just
the thought came in my head and i went
straight to it you know there was no
mental defense no nothing
and um was there something stressful
that kind of caused it or brought it on
i don't see anything that was stressful
as i try to look back at this think that
you know
unconsciously i wanted to get high
and so it moved to the conscious state
and it just is dominating
you know it's it's absolutely dominating
so it's dominated me
and i didn't have any fight
you understand that that's part of the
process right no one goes
i think i'm gaining a better
understanding of hard and fast cause you
know i'm i can kick my ass better than
anybody
you know and yeah even right now i still
feel down about i feel like
i've let a lot of people down and things
like that but the bottom line is god
damn it i'm an addict
and and through the process of recovery
this is going to happen
it's going to happen so roll with the
[ __ ] punches norman
don't beat yourself up don't just
continue to go that's important
and and you know that's hard for me
because i'm a prideful person see
so therefore you know probably got a lot
of [ __ ] to do with it so i'm gonna have
to drop that [ __ ]
you know i'm gonna ask god on a daily
basis just just get get rid of this
because what it's gonna do
is it's gonna lead me down that that uh
that cauldron
and i'm gonna be [ __ ] you know and i
don't want to be [ __ ] no you
shouldn't you shouldn't judge yourself
and say oh i screwed up
you should just be like this is part of
what happened it's a setback no big deal
and i was gonna actually
ask the job for an extra week i'm not
asking for [ __ ]
i'm going to a job thursday good for you
so you start i start thursday thursday
yeah excellent you know i went through
my my training and stuff like that so
i'm going thursday night did you do you
think any of this relapse
is caused by your
you've had some success lately right and
sometimes people have a hard time
accepting
good things in their life success and do
you think if there's any of that like
all of a sudden you got your life
straight and you're
you're getting it back together with
your kids and you have a job and
everything is kind of going in the right
direction
and you need to throw a wrench in the
works i think it was impending doom
and then you doom of an impending doom
of the fear of the unknown
not knowing what's going on what i think
is going to go on
and you're right i mean here's all of
this
monumental success in so much of a small
time
that i've i don't think i got cocky
it was supposed to happen yeah i think
it's part of the process i'm not even
gonna try to try to answer it in any way
shape or form
it was supposed to happen knock me down
a pic hey
just take it easy don't try to do
everything fast
exactly just you know we'll help you
yeah and don't don't judge yourself too
harshly yeah yeah i just i mean i kick
my ass man i feel so bad no no no no
no but i'm getting out of it you know
slowly but shorty
my good friend man um yeah i called him
and he said
where are you so i'm not too far away
he said i'll be here when you get here
you know that's that's a true friend
he didn't judge me anything he gave me a
big old hug he said you're hungry
so i had to get something to eat he said
when the last time you got high i said
well
it was way like six seven in the morning
something like that
you know he said are you sleepy i said
i'm dead tired
you know but yeah we still stayed up and
we talked a little bit and
next thing i know it was morning time
yeah you're lucky to have donald yeah
he's a very very good friend man god
bless them man
absolutely you know it's it's just um
it's supposed to happen
uh they stayed in the rooms that
relapses are part of recovery
so now i'm getting an understanding of
that sometimes you have to
excuse me take a step back in order to
move forward absolutely and if that is
the case then that's the case you know
um
i said before that i really don't worry
about what people say think and feel
but there is a part of me that does yeah
it's human nature you know because
i mean you you do these this story like
my video and
about myself and so many people
commented that was extremely positive
and
you know they were uplifting and i read
them every day yet it was not
substantial enough to stop me
so that means more work needs to be done
you know maybe we've just scratched the
surface we gotta
we we're digging underneath more
you know i asked god just wanted you
know look uncover what the hell is wrong
so i can discover what the [ __ ] is wrong
and i can recover from this [ __ ]
because this [ __ ] is going to kill me
eventually
um some people may
make become you know judgmental during
my journey
and i got to make sure that i take that
you know
um there were a couple of things said
when i went into this uh this mission
for to to live as far as job placement
and stuff like that and there were a few
things said that i
i believe they i don't believe they
triggered me
but i i didn't like what they were
saying oh he well you know he's always
done this so i'm being judged and looked
at in my former sense
but i also have to understand that it's
my present state
so just because they say what they say
you know it does affect me yeah but
it's not it's important to not listen to
anyone else yeah but i gotta i gotta
stray away from that because you know i
have the
the i have the type of mind that has the
ability to [ __ ] me without my permission
so you know god damn
you know i let the smallest things
become the biggest things
you know i mean i'm not religious at all
right i'm the least religious person
you'll ever meet but
but what helps you in these situations
is how would god judge you
i don't think he would he wouldn't and
that's the key
you know i mean i think you know i've
done a lot of these talks 2000 or more
and a lot of them a lot of them have
been with addicts
and what i've learned is addiction is
not the real problem
it's a symptom of a deeper problem and
that deeper problem is a combination of
the unconditional love you didn't
receive as a child and whatever that
takes a million forms
the the the traumatic events that you're
trying to
escape from later on in life the
environment you grow up in and the
brain chemistry that you have and those
all combine to create a scenario where
you
can be self-destructive right and you
can sabotage your your progress and
what's
the problem with with self-love is it's
such a nice little term
right you know i'm gonna go get a
caramel macchiato and and and love
myself today
that's what it's sounds so easy but the
truth of it is
it's more like it's more like
i'm gonna climb mount everest barefoot
with a 75-pound backpack on my
on my shoulders to prepare myself for
the challenge of loving myself
that's what it's going to take it's
going to take a tremendous amount of
strength and courage
to love ourselves it's the biggest
challenge any of us ever have and if you
don't
take it that seriously then you're going
to end up just becoming
you're just going to find any
distraction to kind of numb the pain of
not being happy
yeah and everything is everything is
going to just hurt hurt
hurt and i'm going to say poor me poor
me and i don't want to go into that
state you know
it's slowly but surely uh getting off my
shoulders of what i've done
you know i have to have a degree of
acceptability of what i've done
okay norman you did it accept it move
forward you don't have to stay
in this rut because when i stay in the
rut i keep going
and going and going like the energizing
money i keep going and going
you know um yes i was able to stop
not because i ran out of money well i
did run out of money but
also that that was around it it was
right there
it was accessible all i had to do was
ask but i just didn't want no more
you know i think what happens is you get
a moment of clarity
and that clarity hit me about four
o'clock in the morning
what are you gonna do now you've left
there
now what are you gonna do you got this
child
now what are you gonna do and i was like
okay
i know what i have to do i know what i
need to do
but it isn't really what i want to do
you know do i want to stay out here and
just continue
or do i want to go ahead and say okay
norm you made a mistake
back up take a breath
to go you know i'm still going to my job
still going to work
you know i got [ __ ] one day today
with goddammit i'm going
i'll be there on time way before time
and i'm gonna do my job and i'm gonna
take it easy and stop trying it
see i want to carry everything
i'll say i'll give it to god and i do
but then i'll take some [ __ ] back
okay god thanks a lot i'll take this oh
thanks a lot on this one i'll take this
and i believe and i know it's not i
believe this is what happened
i know what happened yeah i started
it started all blossoming but i put too
much water on it
too much too soon too much too soon
instead of just backing up because see
it's not so much that i say now i've got
it you know this is it
i'm great you're fixed but it's like
okay
i had an overwhelming desire to succeed
but uh
you know it's not really not about
success
am i trying to succeed for me or am i
trying to succeed for the viewers
am i trying to succeed for my family
i can be an impressionable person but
god damn man i'm an addict
and i'm struggling it's about
forgiveness and acceptance i'm an addict
and i'm struggling and
and if this is a part of my recovery
within so be it this is what i have to
do
you know i'm going to have up so i'm
going to have downs i'm going to start
small yeah so
i got gotta gotta start small you know
thank god for my i gotta
give kudos to my friend thank god for
him you know because
you know you don't i don't trust men
i got trust issues and for that man that
look at me with tears in his eyes
last night he gave me a big old hug and
said man i love you you like my brother
anytime you need me i'm gonna be there
for you that
within itself really really um
showed me that i can't trust men because
every man is not like the man that did
what he did to me
you know i i really never said that one
either
because that i didn't trust me and you
know because of what has happened to me
and
you know here's a guy
who really honestly cares about me i'm
no relation to him
but he cares about me unconditionally
there might have been a lot of others in
in life but i didn't based on what has
happened to me
so i was judgmental you know no
[ __ ]
you got your some motive you know and
this man has no motive or nothing
he gave me some necessary stuff to lay
down and i went lay down i went to sleep
you know thank god for him you know i
didn't want to call you
yeah you you worked for a week i didn't
want i didn't want you you lost your
phone too
yeah you know and um yeah this is never
i lost a wallet
which i have to get all that stuff back
i lost my phone
got to get that one back went to the
mission this morning to get my stuff
it's gone so i'm back to square
one so if i'm in training
ie orientation for a new life
i'm starting back to square one i'm
sorry i'm starting back at square one
yeah
you know i think there'll be more
setbacks yeah yeah yeah you know maybe i
have to be stripped
because i've never lost my wallet don't
be hard on yourself though
yeah but you know you got to do it you
got to do it and we can do it
you know it can be done i do have the
wherewithal inside
to do it and you'll have you have good
days and bad days yeah and i just have
to
get back mark i have to garner a sense
of acceptability that's what it is see i
don't accept
failure
at all i failed okay [ __ ] it
but something now is different because i
had that moment of clarity
i listened to that little voice
it took me a while to access somebody's
phone because i was extremely tired
and i called my buddy
and he was right there for me i'm not an
addict so forgive me if i'm off base for
sure but it seems like it might
be i can relate to aspects of you know
things in my life
you know i don't do drugs but it's like
there's other things that are basically
the same thing
you you you made a couple steps forward
and you made a step back but where you
are perhaps today
is a little tiny bit better than where
you were yesterday
a month and a half ago right yes right
yes you're improving
yes if you look at it on a daily basis
you're having big ups and big downs
right
right exactly what you just said i mean
over the long haul okay what i've taken
i guess my foot is up now it's not even
down yet
it's up so i'm making a stride forward
yeah
you know because i wouldn't usually i
wouldn't be here
are you better off today than you were
three months ago
i think i'm getting there yeah that's a
good attitude i think i'm getting there
um this this little well no not a little
this run
i've seen a little bit more than what i
usually see
um
i see how it's changing people and you
know when you
when you come from a sober state and go
into this
i don't know about other people for me i
watch everything and i'm
i'm watching some [ __ ] that's just i'm
like god damn
but i'm continuing to smoke because i
don't know i'm gonna do that but i'm
looking at it man and it's just
it's ugly it's really really ugly
and um
bottom line is we got to grasp that
wherewithal again
but take it slow with the weather though
yeah take it slow you're
you're demanding a little too much of
yourself right right you know
it's your subconscious that needs to
change not your conscience because
you're conscious
you're you're intelligent enough to know
that drugs are bad and this lifestyle
living on the street is is destructive
it's not about that no it's 100
it's loud it's it's all about
what your subconscious belief is about
yourself and what you deserve
right and once that really changes then
all of a sudden you'd be like why the
hell did i ever spend time down there
but but you can't you're not there yet
so you can't demand that of yourself
and um just got to dig deeper
and what is going to happen slowly uh i
don't think recovery is a fast process
at all no you know i mean it takes
people some time
and for whatever it takes they have to
work through issues and things like that
so i got to go i got to go through some
[ __ ] you know
sometimes i'm going to stand maybe i
might fall i don't know
but at least i'm giving an honest effort
to do so yeah no you're you're doing
everything right
in my eyes i just think it's not an
addiction issue it looks like it looks
like oh you're a drug addict and that's
the problem
to me it's a self-love issue and you are
making
incremental changes in your ability to
love yourself
because this can be the hardest thing
you ever change as i said earlier it's
going to be the hardest thing we ever
change about ourselves
and it doesn't happen like that right
you know even even if you have a
wonderful change like you you get a
great job back you know making the money
you used to make and all that kind of
stuff all these wonder and a great woman
in your life and
whatever you want all these great things
that happen to you
you won't make a miraculous change in
your subconscious belief about yourself
overnight it's still going to take a
long time to change
yeah and that's why people who who have
had huge success will self-sabotage us
because they
they weren't ready for that much success
yeah i asked myself
donald asked me last night he said man
do you fear success
first time in my life i ever said yes
he looked at me he said okay
he said you remember they asked us that
question a couple of years ago when we
were both in the same place i said yeah
he said you were only one out of the
group to say hell no
he said but you do it's the fear of the
unknown
fear of success he said man you'll find
it
yeah it's great that you're aware of
that yeah because
you're confident and you're competent
you're self-assured and you're you're
you have all these great qualities
right but that doesn't mean you still
can't doubt yourself and and feel like
you're
not deserving yeah that's common i'm
how many beautiful women are insecure
all of them
almost all i agree i agree um i mean
it's just it
man we're just gonna keep going
so i get a better meaning though i woke
up about six o'clock this morning
my buddy was asleep and i was just
staring at the window
and something came in and said slowly
but surely
slowly but surely and i'm like okay
i read that as your ass went too damn
fast
you didn't check the boat fully before
you sailed and that's why your punk ass
[ __ ] around you got a hole in the bow
and you but you didn't drown you didn't
drive
you had the wherewithal to swim
to the shore yeah so now that you're on
the shore you don't have to lay down on
the sand norman
i i don't see you any differently today
than i did yeah
during our last two talks which were
really positive right you're the same
person
yeah you're just having a bad day bad
week bad month
whatever but i believe in you and i
think you're doing amazing work
thank you very much we're gonna we're
gonna do it one day at a time
we'll continue and uh you guys will
surely see me again
absolutely you can believe that no we're
gonna do it
excellent all right very good luck this
week thank you all right man thanks
damn for some reason something just went
ah
i think cause i've finally admitted that
i'll fear success
having these talks are great cause
granny drove me my grandmother
i mean she's a businesswoman she owned
five cleaners she's president of the
mother's board
she's president of her eastern star
which is a women's form of the
uh uh what do you call them oh [ __ ]
masons you know i had i
came home one day there's senator john
conyers on one
side of this couch and mayor coleman
young on the other one
and i'm like but they were talking to
her about
her testifying against robert
chamberlain robertson richard
chamberlain and robert chad i think he's
one of those
he was the guy who planted the bomb in
the sixth street baptist church
that killed those four girls and my
grandmother seen him
and testify against him in 1977 he died
in 81.
and i'm sitting up here looking i never
knew i remember when fbi agents came to
our house
and i say hey grandma she said who's
that at the door i says four white guys
with badges
is in detroit yeah and she said oh yes
yeah put them in put them in the den
they went in then they closed the door
and they were there for some hours
and i remember they left and my grandma
said well um
i'm going to be gone for a couple of
weeks i'm like wait i'll tell you when i
get back
and i think three days later my
grandfather said oh that's a good
picture
i said who he said your grandma looked
i said granny testify
she's the woman who's got one of those
guys convicted
you know and i was like wow man
so her
her positions my family's position yeah
you know you gotta
you're a fundraiser you gotta stand up
you know i've never been able to stand
up to that [ __ ] cause i really didn't
want to a lot of pressure
yeah too much i go to 24th street school
and the teachers say oh this is normally
fine all your sisters are dorothy and
danita
they're straight a's one behind each
other
uh valedictorian valedictorian so guess
what i was valedictorian
so i'm following in these footsteps and
it's like this pressure you've got to
succeed you've got to succeed you've got
to see
when all and all essence i fear that
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] man
and i've never admitted what the [ __ ]
i'm saying right now scared to death
i went to the interview at disney scared
to death
didn't know what was going to come out
when that guy told me he says norman
what are you doing after the interview i
said well i'm going home
he said well i'm going to have lunch why
don't you join me
i knew i had the job then and it eased
that but i was
scared to death i'm going up against uh
some powerful people
you know some pretty pretty astute
engineers you know
and i got the [ __ ] job you know
i mean you're in charge of 260 engineers
i go to
disney world and eurodisney
you know i'm all expenses paid i mean
i'm living the life of riley and
i was sober there so were
well that's over two and a half years
when i got the job stay sober six years
ten months and two days brought it down
because i stopped doing what i was doing
to get there you know
and uh yeah i fear success
yeah i do so we'll see what happens
yes we will yup we'll see you many times
bro yes sir
thank you yeah anytime
you